andre and elizabeth first things first
what are your thoughts on watching the
season back so far
honestly watching it back we're just
like holy crap
you don't know how things are until you
like see it
and you see how you're acting and there
are some embarrassing moments but then
there's also moments where you're like
oh i love you
yeah it's been a lot of events and uh
you know when you watch yourself
sometimes you just like feel but you
might have done something better or
sometimes you just like
you know yeah you don't feel anything
you definitely think like oh i could
have said that better or
that could have come off a different way
because now people think i'm saying this
but i didn't really mean that so
you just like have all those thoughts in
your head but mostly we don't care what
people think it's
our you know like it's our journey so
it's mostly about us and everything else
doesn't matter
well what do you make andre of some
viewers who say
you have been very rude to elizabeth
uh i i don't think that i'm rude like
we're
loving each other and uh you know like
we get all of this uh
you know like we'll get this boots all
the time and i think
i'm not rude at all do you think i'm
rude i think that
just your culture and where you're from
they're very blunt
and they're very cutthroat and people
may or may not be able to handle that
and it may come across as like super
rude but
to me i understand him where he's coming
from and i know that it's not like a jab
at me
or intentionally being rude to me i
think that that's just his voice and his
accent and like
him being a man i think you throw all
that in together and then it's just like
it comes off as rude and
i don't take it that way sometimes you
can be
very very rude but you too by the way
majority of the time i understand
i can't bring my family here and have
them
don't interrupt me i can't breathe
he actually called you out of your name
and a lot of fans were trying to figure
out
what exactly you said andre um that was
like there were people saying like
some bizarre things like saying he was
like cussing at me and stuff and i'm
like
that's not what he said it doesn't
really make a really problem
i mean because tlc bleeped it out but
what did you say i probably you know
like i was
jet lag that was you know like this was
the couple of days
like we were watching like we were
seeing uh venues like
wedding venues and i was frustrated she
was frustrated and it actually happened
but
she actually uh i said shut up yes
she said it's like first and i got you
know like i got upset
and that's when it started but i don't
know like i curse sometimes i'm not
gonna hide it and
i may be cursed a lot before we started
filming in the day we
had an argument and i think i told him
to shut up and then that just kind of
started out in the day and then
he was like no you shut up later on you
got a little bit of friction and after
this we're just like
we exploded but we shouldn't say that to
each other it's like really
disrespectful
yeah it seems like you two have an
understanding of each other that
i mean of course the audience doesn't
have so when we see it
i mean we clutch our pearls we're like
oh my goodness but for you too you've
got you can kind of breathe
past it that's what it seems like i
think a lot of people have
their own trouble because i don't really
know a couple that will not ever have a
disagreement
i know but as they watch us on tv
and uh some people some some points are
actually you know like highlighted
uh they realize you know like what
you're like wow
like they're fighting so much they have
like so much uh you know like red flags
and blah blah blah
but at the same time you should look
under your nose you know like
you really don't know yourself because i
i can
bet everybody has disagreements and it
must be
so much worse than ours we're just one
of the very few that are
willing to show our journey and our
goods and our bads
not everybody's relationship is perfect
and like oh
lovey-dovey like we're all human we
fight at times we yell at each other and
we're just willing to
show people that side of us too yeah
yeah
it does come off intense sometimes you
all like i mean i get everybody has
disagreements but sometimes
it's like wow andre you're talking down
to her and elizabeth you're really good
at just
you know keeping your cool and moving
onto the
subject what do you make of people
saying that
you know andre can be condescending or
rude towards you
um so watching it back i can see what
they would
see watching it like i can understand
what they're saying but um
again like i know my husband and i know
that he wouldn't purposefully try to put
me down
i think he just is like such a strong
person and he comes off like really mean
at times but to me like i understand
what you're saying she's a strong
she's a strong person to like and uh
you like sometimes uh you know like she
gets like the top uh
you like uh thinking about this but what
we have so she's like
sometimes she she does it to me and but
it's not shown
and they they you like they put me like
in there but
you're like you know bad light but this
actually happens she does it too
because she's very strong she's very
stubborn but
nine times out of ten i do bite my
tongue because i feel like if i
fuel the fire it will just get bigger
and bigger bigger bigger so i'd rather
just like
keep my cool and not get upset about it
i feel better by my tongue sometimes too
actually but
yes sure i guess
yeah honestly you're a lucky man because
you found your match because
a lot of a lot of women wouldn't feel
comfortable
you know in that situation and she
definitely understands you so just
take note of that and treat elizabeth
very kindly please i don't need a lot of
i don't need a lot of women i have one
like lucky lucky for you you found
someone that understands you
because they're and that takes you is
what she's saying
i guess so yeah thank you elizabeth for
just getting to the first
well something i'm curious about
elizabeth when it comes to you and your
family
it seems like when we watch it back when
it's you know your mom your sister your
dad everyone around you and andre
it's kind of like them against you two
has it
have you always had that family dynamic
where maybe you were the one always
doing your own thing
or is family drama a new thing for you i
feel like for me as my personality i've
always been one to like stand out in my
family like
i think a little bit differently than
them and i've just been more like
adventurous
and just wanted to kind of like do my
own thing and not necessarily follow
what my family's doing
and just with that i get the attention
drawn to me and they're like no you're
not supposed to do that so like they
always have like an opinion
and i feel like bringing a day into the
mix like it just made it that much worse
and they're like
pointing their fingers and having all
these opinions so plus she's
she's the youngest girl and uh you know
like everybody's
protecting over her they think that they
know everything
second of all they never left america or
they did it's not true
some of them did some of them like it's
like
one and you're like they don't even know
like what's going on outside
of work so yeah it's a mix of everything
else how does it feel to be in that
position where you do have you know your
husband
throwing shade in every now and then
towards your family and then you have
your family throwing shade every now and
then towards him i mean i know that's a
sticky position for you to be in
i know it's really tip for chat and i
feel like
sometimes depending on my mood and if
i'm mad at someone like it kind of feels
good for him to like
say something and like defend me but
then at other times like my family's
being rude to him and i'm like
well you were a jerk earlier today so
that's what you get
but it definitely is something that i
consider and i'm like okay i don't want
like i don't want them to always fight
but like
they have their differences and they
just need to work it out well andre is
there anything that
fans may not know about elizabeth from
watching the show that you you think
they should know
uh i think she's a sweetheart i think
she's
loving but she has her you know like she
she can show her teeth it happens it
happens and
um i can't i i'm handling them
i tame her i guess so
that's what we're talking about andre
those are the comments
no you mean i trained you
okay well elizabeth same question for
you is there anything about andre
that you think the world does not know
and they should
andrei is such an amazing father and
he's super super sweet and
he's actually a really goofy person at
heart and he has
a really soft spot for people and his
heart that he loves
dearly and are really close to him and i
feel like we don't see enough of that
side because
obviously like showing our journey it
can be stressful and i feel like a lot
of times
you lose sight of like your actual self
and you're just like so caught up in the
moment so i feel like a lot of times
he's not able to really show
his sweet self and you are a sweetheart
baby like you really are a sweet guy
she's very romantic you are
traitor take the compliment andre
you